ix assists in the game for Luka since go  ahead assist when he found cleaveth  around the horn shadow degree  [Applause]  and here's for why you could try to dig  in and keep him out of there last of all  oh it bounced off his lower leg he  picked it up he finds Landry [ __ ] again  somebody else to beat you up the victor  while goes into Cleveland right back to  Lucca turns a corner comes down the lane  flips in apartments got the bounce  Leonard has been along with Shiva the  life givers like the game killer  she don't bother to why he's continued  to play this game  [Music]  we could answer with a straight back  [Applause]  I'm gonna be a dreamer pity 50 drives  baseline  [Applause]  twenty-sixth loses scores a point six to  play the game